[Music]
every week
tyler gave the rules that he and i
welcome to decided club
the first rule of fight club is you do
not talk about my club
second rule of fight club is you do not
talk about fight club third rule of
fight club
someone yells stop goes limp taps out
the fight is over fourth rule
only two guys to a fight fifth rule
one fight at a time fellas sixth rule
no shirts no shoes seventh rule
fights will go on as long as they have
to
and the eighth and final rule if this is
your first night at fight club
you have to fight me who are you
hey i'm an award-winning scrim chandler
b i'm a moderately influential warlord
c i write personality quizzes for
magazines
okay well your hands are far too
delicate for real scrimshaw work
and i happen to be a charter subscriber
to middling warlord weekly so i'd
recognize you
i'm gonna go with c and you
who are you i'm the guy to save you
from all this awesomeness
who am i speaking with this is the
zodiac
speaking
is there something i can call you that's
a little less ominous
sam sam
is there somewhere we can meet sam and
talk about this
meet me on top of the fairmont hotel
without anyone else have a unit go to
the fairmont hotel
yes do you think you need medical care
medical not mental do you have health
problems
i'm sick i've headaches headaches
i have headaches too but a chiropractor
has stopped them a week ago
i think i can help you sam
[Music]
mel from mark telling me to come out for
the millionth member party what else did
the email say
it said that we had to have a business
meeting but mark and sean had played
some kind of revenge stunt on case
equity
that manningham was so impressed that he
was now making an investment offer that
was hard to turn down
so i went to california and i went
straight to the new offices
i didn't know whether to dress for the
party or for the business meeting
so i kind of dressed for both
but it didn't matter why not because i
wasn't called out there for either one
what were you called out there for
an ambush
and what's this old man's jurisdiction
he's got the devil on his back trying to
ride him into the grave before his time
up zappy car yes out diesel ball
how old are you seven but i look a lot
older
god bless you e7
now this is a man with optimism in his
heart
all right belief in his soul we are all
children in the eyes of god
we are gonna get you out of that chair
people in the house hey
you're in the elevator pull them down
ah
they're going downstairs
that room the panic room
no you got a first emergency stop
i had the arena down there in that cage
who is irina you might ask
just another girl just another immigrant
[ __ ]
who misses your sister what
your sister harry wasn't just another
girl
you found her
what happened to her
what was in the box because i envy your
normal life put the gun down baby it
seems that
envy is myself oh what's in the box
what's in the
shut up that's what he wants what he
wants you to shoot him
no no
you tell me you tell me that's not true
that's not true become vengeance dude
ah she's all right you tell me you come
wrath tell me she's all right she made
her a suspect david
no just throw it all away you know
for her life to take that shut up she
paid for her life shut up
and for the life of the baby inside of
[Music]
her
[Music]
[Music]
you